all right hello everyone welcome to
another episode of Science and
Technology Q&A for kids and others sorry
I'm starting slightly late today uh we
were just wrapping up our annual Wolfram
winter School talking about uh our
physics project mostly for graduate
students and others studying those kinds
of things um lots of interesting
projects got done
there okay so let's uh let's talk about
some things here
I see a
question came in asks why is there
matter at all in the universe why is the
universe not just empty it's a good
question uh well let's let's talk about
that
the they're
different it I think we're in a better
position to answer that question because
of the progress we've made in
understanding fundamental physics from
our wol physics project in the last few
years but let's uh let's give it a
try one question is what what what what
is what is the universe fundamentally
made of the traditional view has been
there's space there's kind of the extent
of space there's kind of you can move
things around to different positions in
space and then there's things that you
put in space like atoms or electrons or
photons or or us or whatever else that
there are these two different kinds of
things that there's this sort of
background of space it's like you've got
your blank sheet of paper that is the
space in the universe and then all of
the all of the sort of things we care
about the content of the universe is the
things you draw on that blank sheet of
paper so from that point of view you
could ask the question well why is there
anything other than just the blank sheet
of paper in fact
in uh traditional models of physics it
gets even more uh it I don't think it's
very easy to explain why there would be
any matter in the universe why the
universe wouldn't just be pure empty
space now there is a little bit of a
footnote to that even in traditional
models of physics because one of the
phenomena we've known for a 100 years
happens is this phenomenon of quantum
fluctuations so in our typical sort of
view of what's happening in the world we
sort of imagine that there are definite
things happening in the world but
quantum mechanics kind of the theory of
sort of what happens at small scales
says actually that isn't right definite
things don't happen there are always
many different Paths of History being
followed at least that's that's the
interpretation of it that we have now in
the last few years that there are sort
of many paths of history that are being
followed and when we humans observe the
universe and this is really my
interpretation of this at this point um
is that we humans are kind of
aggregating we we're putting together a
bunch of these different Paths of
History just as if we were differently
set up we might be able to observe every
individual molecule bouncing around in
the air but as it is we only observe
sort of the aggregate the average of the
effects of lots and lots of molecules so
similarly a little bit more difficult to
understand we're only uh we're only
observing kind of the average of many
paths of History okay but there's this
phenomenon that on each different path
of History the detailed configuration of
what electrons anti- electrons etc etc
etc exist at any given place in space is
different and this leads to this idea of
quantum fluctuations uh fluctuations the
the idea that at any moment there are
always these kind of so-called virtual
partic particle antiparticle pairs being
produced so it's like an electron a
positon the anti-electron come into
existence for a very short time then
they annihilate again and that keeps on
happening throughout the universe so
even if you believe that there is no
matter in the universe there is still uh
well in the traditional theory one would
always have some um yeah many pieces to
this the maybe better thing to do is not
to try and explain the traditional
theory which gets itself horribly
Tangled Up um when we start discussing
the relationship of matter to gravity to
vacuum fluctuations and so on uh in our
models of physics what is going on is
that we don't distinguish sort of space
and matter as separate kinds of things
instead the whole universe what is
really there is just this giant Network
and each the the network is represents
connections between these very abstract
elements we can call them atoms of space
they're not atoms in the sense of
hydrogen helium those kinds of atoms
they're just indivisible points in
effect
that represent the sort of smallest
components of space and in our models
space has a definite structure it's it's
made of this giant graph that connects
together these individual elements that
sort of represent disembodied points in
space and all we know is kind of how
these these points are connected in this
graph and then the question is well what
is matter if that's if the structure of
space is determined by this big graph
what is matter well matter is certain
persistent features in the structure of
this graph this graph is continually
getting Rewritten every time there's a
little piece of graph that has some
particular form it gets transformed into
a piece of graph that has some other
form this keeps happening one one's just
sort of evolving this graph and matter
in this interpretation is kind of pieces
of that graph that are uh that are
somewhat
stable through time and that could
happen the analogy I I tend to give of
this in a fluid with a bunch of
molecules bouncing around underneath you
can still have an Eddie that is kind of
a spinning around piece of fluid that is
is fairly stable you can see it sort of
move along you know in in in Basin of
water or something like this it it it
has a certain identity that it maintains
even though it's continually made from
different the different molecules that
are the ones that are actually
contributing to the structure of Eddie
but the Eddie itself has a continued
existence and and that's what we think
matter how we think matter Works in uh
uh in this in in this model of the
universe where there's the sort of
underlying graph that represents the
structure of everything structure of
space but there are certain features of
that graph that we interpret as matter
and matter as far as we know right now
has uh we can sort of break down matter
into particles like electrons and quarks
and photons and so on everything that we
think of as matter can be thought of as
something which is a a small lump of
stuff that maintains its character as it
travels through space and as it uh
progresses through time we can sort of
think of all of matter as broken down
into those kinds of lumps in our model
of physics it's not absolutely necessary
that everything that is persistent in
time can be broken into lumps in that
kind of way and there might be other
forms of quotes matter that don't get
sort of don't get decomposed as
particles in the same way in fact for
example Dark Matter something that has
been known about for 100 years that has
a a gravitational effect but seems to
have no other effect it's possible that
that is a quotes form of matter that
cannot be represented in terms of these
sort of lumps of stuff that Cor respond
to particles so this question of why is
there why would there be matter in the
universe why would there be anything
that is sort of persistent in the
universe as opposed to just having space
where the space is continually getting
Rewritten and changing and so on why is
there anything that has stability that
we can identify as matter um and I think
that's that in our models becomes
essentially a pure in a sense theortical
question it's it's something which is a
question can you derive in our models
the fact that anything would be
persistent I suspect the answer is that
that the that is inevitable that there
will be things that are persistent in
that sense in our models there's sort of
a a uh and this is getting deeply
abstract we're we're far down the rabbit
hole here um in our models there's this
idea of what we call the ruad which is
I've talked about this network and these
rewrites of the network and so on the
ruard Is What You Get by looking at all
possible rewritings of a system all
possible computations that sort of
figure out what the next state of a
system will be and kind of the big idea
is that we are observers of the ruad and
we are sampling particular possibilities
in the set of all all conceivable
computations and I think so my my guess
is that the reason that the the the
samplings we take of the ruad that give
us the laws of physics that we
experience necessarily correspond to
things that have a certain where we are
identifying certain persistence because
we identify ourselves as having a
certain persistence boy this is deep in
the rabbit hole see one of the things
that is very non-trivial about our way
of exper experiencing the universe is
that we believe that the Universe has a
certain persistence and what it does but
in order to detect that we ourselves
have to be
persistent and that's not a trivial
assumption because in these models of
physics at every successive moment of
time we're made of different atoms of
space it's like that Eddie moving
through the water at every moment it's
made of different water molecules yet if
you imagine that that Eddie was a mind
kind of uh you know if you made up a a
whole brains worth of eddies interacting
with each other and so on to those
Eddies it would seem that they could
they could say we are we persistently
exist we are maintaining our thoughts
through time so to speak even though at
the smallest scales there are different
molecules being swapped in and out for
what make up those edies and so it is I
think with us that we believe we are
persistent in time we have a certain
persistent set of activity that that we
have a certain persistence to to to how
we perceive things that is a question of
of an assumption that we make we assume
that we are persistent in time with the
thoughts we had a moment ago are
connected to the thoughts we have now
and so on even though the the raw
material from which those thoughts are
made is different at every successive
moment in time so my guess is boy this
Got Deep In The Rabbit Hole my guess is
that the fact that we have that
persistence inevitably means that the
kind of slice of the ruad that
corresponds to the universe as we
perceive it um also has certain
persistence and that's why we believe
that there are persistent things in the
world that we can describe as matter and
that that's sort of why matter is exists
for observers Like Us in the universe
that got incredibly philosophical I I am
I'm sort of surprised at how
philosophical the answer to that
question gets that sort of the the
persistent things in the universe exist
because we believe we are persistent in
observing the
universe let's
see okay Lord asks a question how does
friction affect the motion of an
object well what is friction you know
you you have a thing and you're you are
trying to move one sort of block of wood
uh across the floor or something and
there is resistance to motion there is
the the block of wood doesn't want to
slide well what causes that resistance
to motion actually the details of how
that works have been pretty confusing
and the the basic law of sort of how
much friction Force there is was
discovered 400 years ago but it still
isn't really completely understood what
is that law the law says the amount of
friction the amount of force that's
going to push back on you trying to push
something forwards is proportional to
the essentially the weight of the object
the the normal force the force with
which the object sort of pushes into the
floor multiplied by some Factor called
the coefficient of friction usually
denoted mu Greek letter mu so different
kinds of materials have different
coefficients of friction some slide very
easily like ice for example will have a
low coefficient of friction things slide
easily on Ice some things have a very
high coefficient of friction they uh
it's very hard to get them to slide
against each other
and but what causes it to be hard to
slide at all well okay let's talk about
what a solid object is a solid object
has a bunch of atoms in if you looked at
it at a small enough scale it' be made
of a bunch of atoms and those atoms are
organized in some way so that the solid
so that they're more or less fixed in
position two kinds of solid objects
crystals and So-Cal amorphous materials
so in a Crystal the atoms are arranged
in a very regular way like for example
in a salt crystal it would be arranged
in a cubic lattice so it's just like you
have a bunch of of cubicle boxes and you
stack them all up and you put atoms you
know in the at the centers of those
boxes for example or on the corners of
those boxes and that's the arrangement
of atoms in the salt crystal in
something like
glass atoms are arranged in a much more
random way you're just packing in those
those silicon oxygen atoms and so on
just uh sort of packing them in just
like if you took took a bunch of balls
you threw them in a ball pit that's how
you get a so-called amorphous solid so
now the question is when we're talking
about friction the issue is what happens
at the surface of the solid do you have
when when if you've got friction between
two things you're saying how does one
surface of one solid slide against the
surface of another another solid so in a
crystal for example you can potentially
cut the crystal in such a way that
you're just cutting right down a plane
of atoms so that it's very very
perfectly regular that's something you
see in so-call cleavage planes for
crystals if you if you pick the right
angle the crystal will sort of come
apart and you'll have a perfectly flat
face almost perfectly flat face let's
consider that case first so let's say
you've got two crystals and they've all
been they've been sort of perfectly
cleaved and you're trying to slide them
against each
other well the first thing that happens
is if you do that in space they'll stick
typically those two surfaces they'll
just they won't actually slide they'll
just those the the the atoms of one
surface will interact with the atoms of
the other surface and they'll
essentially make an extended solid it's
like the the atoms on one side of if
it's two pieces of metal that let's say
the same metal it's like well you know
why would we distinguish the atoms that
are in one piece of metal from the atoms
in the other piece of metal they just
make a bigger Crystal so to speak what
happens on on you know
not and that's assuming that the the
surface of the crystal is just a perfect
arrangement of these atoms in practice
if you're you know out in the air and
things like this the surface of that
Crystal will have all kinds of air
molecules that get stuck on it and and
there'll be sort of chemical reactions
that happen little chemical reactions
that happen that produce changes in that
surface and so it won't be this
perfect atomically perfect surface that
would have this feature that it can sort
of automatically weld to another surface
and so you're already seeing there's a
big mess here because the the details of
how friction Works depend on things like
well how clean is the surface things
like this by the way it's not surprising
it depends on how clean the surface is
we kind of know that lubrication with
oil and things like this can affect um
how much things slide and and so details
of the surface are going to affect it
the basic the thing that's a bit
surprising is if you push down harder it
becomes harder to slide things why does
that happen it's not really clear why
that happens kind of a possible theory
is that the surface of the material is
always like kind of a mountain scape and
so what's happening is
uh you you're sort of pushing two
mountain Scapes together and if you
don't push terribly hard the only things
that are actually sort of uh against
each other are the tips of the mountains
and when there are only a small number
of tips of mountains the amount of sort
of frictional force associated with
atoms uh pulling on each other is lower
if you push down you're kind of crushing
those Mountain Scapes and so there's a
larger area of contact between the two
surfaces at at the level of atom
and so you have more frictional so you
have more the the the the surfaces are
are are less prepared to slide against
each
other but
um the uh um that's that's kind of um
the story of of um uh again it's not
very well understood I mean what
fundamentally happens in friction what
fundamentally happens is when you push
an object all the atoms in that object
are moving the way you push them but
what's going on is in the end that that
motion is is it's as you push those
atoms and they interact with the atoms
in the other surface all the atoms are
kind of getting moved around wiggled
around and what's happening is that in
the end there's the that that wiggling
around of atoms produces heat in these
surfaces heat is in fact just the
microscopic motion of molecules and so
what's happening in friction is you're
going from this large scale mechanical
process of sliding one block against the
other to this small scale phenomenon of
lots of sort of random motions of
molecules down at the at the level of of
what's happening in these surfaces so
sort of the big picture is friction is
about turning systematic motion into
heat and the sort of the amount of
friction depends on many details of
these surfaces so I don't think there's
any case where one can compute from sort
of first principles the coefficient of
friction I think one always has to
measure it and I think that in what can
happen without an atmosphere and things
like that is you simply get sort of
immediate welding of surfaces
immediately the surfaces just locked
together um at least with crystals not
with amorphous materials I think
um another phenomenon in in friction is
that the static coefficient of friction
is larger than the dynamic one and that
means when you kind of are pushing on
something there'll be a moment when it
sticks and then once it started to move
and there's a big resistance to it
starting to move but once it's started
to move you have to push it less hard to
keep it going then you have to push it
to start it going in the first place and
that phenomenon of of the sort of stick
slip phenomenon is important because for
example earthquakes are the result of
that phenomenon because you you know the
rock is continually across a fault line
in the Earth the rock is continually
being sort of pushed two two pieces of
rock are being pushed relative to each
other and most of the time they don't
move at all but suddenly they they start
they unstick and they start moving and
once they've started moving for that
moment when the earthquake is happening
they find it easier to move than it took
than it was for them to start moving in
the first place there also when we talk
about you know anti-lock brakes for cars
cars when the car is sort of sliding on
ice and so on and uh there's there's
sort of this question of of whether you
can make use of the fact that there's a
um uh a higher resistance to starting to
slide than there is to Sliding once you
are sliding so to
speak let's
see
uh well there's a question here from
from Paula
what is the relationship between force
mass and
acceleration this was the great
achievement of Isaac Newton in
1687 kind of launched the the serious
kind of mathematical science of
mechanics and his second law says force
is equal to mass times
acceleration and when you really take it
apart it's not clear quite from the
outside what the second law means other
than that it defines the notion of force
but let's talk about what these Notions
are so what is
acceleration so uh when you have
something moving you can describe it as
oh it's going at such and such a speed
that means the speed is the amount it
changes its position in a certain amount
of time so let's say we're walking at 2
miles per hour that means in we are
going we're changing our position by two
miles in the course of one
hour okay but but now the question is
that that's that's velocity that speed
is how much we're changing our position
uh in the in the course of time now the
question is do we change our speed in
the course of time do we are we just
going at a constant speed or is our
speed changing so acceleration is the
rate at which we are changing our speed
so for example we might say you know we
we put our foot on the gas for a car and
it accelerates because it changes its
speed from being let's say zero miles
per hour to 60 mil hour and the
acceleration is the rate at which we are
changing the speed of the thing and we
can we can keep going you know we we can
say well the uh uh the velocity is the
rate of change of position acceleration
is the rate of change of velocity
there's this thing that often is called
jerk which is the rate of change of
acceleration how much a thing jerks you
know the kind of human perception of
that was a uh you know that that you
know really jerk to a stop or something
like this that's looking at the change
of acceleration
typically and um so the uh but in any
case acceleration is is just defined as
this thing about how things move and how
the rate of the the rate of change of
position
works well so that's a thing that has a
definite meaning now there's the
question of of uh
Mass well uh what is mass well there are
actually two very different meanings two
very different things that correspond to
the mass of an object one is how
difficult it is to make that object
start to move how much force you have to
put to get that object to move a c at a
certain speed that's one sort of measure
of mass which is actually just comes
from Newton's Second Law Force equals
masstimes acceleration I told you this
was a bit of a put up job and a sort of
circular definitional thing but so one
version of mass is the thing that
appears in that formula another version
of mass is uh how much the is pulled by
the force of gravity so one can have the
mass of something which is the so-called
inertial Mass the the mass that is
associated with the inertia of the
object how much how much it takes to get
the object moving in a certain way
another thing one can look at is how
much the object is pulled down to the
ground so to speak by the force of
gravity and the the amount it's pulled
down one talks about the mass of an
object which is associated with how
difficult it is to get the object moving
let's say it's on a frictionless table
and you're just sort of getting the
object to move around the heavier it is
the harder you have to push it to get it
to move but now the next question is
well the the the the the uh the higher
the mass is the more you have to push it
in that scenario but the higher the mass
the more it's going to push down as a
result of it being pulled by the force
of gravity
and so there's another formula also due
to Newton which is the formula for law
of gravity that says that the force
associated with gravity is proportional
to the mass okay so it is a non-trivial
fact that the mass that is associated
with sort of how hard you have to push
the thing to get it moving is the same
mass quantity that determines the force
of an object produced by gravity the
equivalence between inertial and
gravitational mass is a thing that is
sort of a big feature of general
relativity it's the so-called principal
equivalence um that was developed in
1915 by by Einstein and uh actually in
um uh well this in in in our models of
physics it is inevitably true um and
it's also inevitably true in the kind of
uh uh in the framework for thinking
about space time that that General
ativity has but so that's a that's
another piece to the picture is there's
this parameter Mass you know that
there's this thing Force equals mass
times acceleration okay what is mass
well we can independently measure mass
by saying that it is the amount that
gravity pulls on something that's an
independent measurement it's not obvious
it be the same mass but it turns out it
is the same mass so what is
force well
Force I'm afraid it's very circular
because force is kind of this this thing
that is quite an abstract thing that's
the the that represents kind of whose
effect is to make something accelerate
but Force has all kinds of rules about
it like for example if you have um uh
sort of you can force is in a particular
direction you can have two forces that
cancel you can have something where when
when whenever things are in equilibrium
whenever things aren't moving if I have
my two two hands so to speak and I'm
pushing one way with a force in this
direction I'm pushing force in that
direction if they're not going to move
that means those two forces have to be
equal and opposite that's the only way I
can get the thing to not accelerate if
if one if one hand was pushing harder
than the other with more Force I would
start accelerating in a particular
direction so actually Newton's third law
has to do with the idea that with every
reaction there's an equal every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
and that is essentially the consequence
of the fact that if you have forces
pushing in two different directions the
only way that their effect can be
canceled out is if the two forces are
equal by the way just to fill in
Newton's Laws of Motion the the the
first law is kind of a a special case of
the second law it says if you have an
object that is not acted on by any
external Force then it will keep going
at a constant speed in a particular
direction so by the way in the time in
Newton's time to make that claim was not
obvious because today we might easily be
able to have some nice you know air
hockey table or something where we can
you know push a puck and we can see that
it it starts going and it just keeps
going in that direction but in Newton's
time the number of things that didn't
have lots of friction associated with
them wasn't large so the claim that you
could have a thing that would just once
you push in a particular direction it
will keep going in that direction if it
isn't acted on by a force including the
force of friction um that that that
would happen was was not so obvious it
was important to Newton in what he was
figuring out because he was trying to
understand the motion of planets and in
that case he imagined that uh planets
wouldn't have any Force other than Gra
ity acting on them which is more or less
correct but um so you know the fact that
Newton was able to come up with this law
of motion Force equals mass times
acceleration and so on the the thing
that was non-trivial about that was just
identifying what kind of a law one
should try to come up with in other
words to say we can distinguish a
material object and we just have to talk
about the motion of that object we don't
have to talk about about what that
object is doing you know if the object
is a person when the person moves the
person is walking their legs and is
moving around or they're swimming and
they're you know flapping their arms
around and so on um you know there's
there's lots going on with the object
the the fact that you could just have an
inert object and you could talk about
its motion and the effect of things on
that motion that was a that was a
nonrival realization that that was a
thing about which you could make a
theory uh it was that that's always one
of the challeng es in making up
scientific theories is how do you
concentrate on one particular thing and
successfully idealize away everything
else how can you just say I'm going to
concentrate on the the motion of this
one thing acted on by forces this that
and the other rather than saying well I
have to cover I have to have a theory
that describes how everything fits
together let's
see gool is asking can you explain the
difference between static and kinetic
friction in the context of Newton's laws
no Newton's Laws do not address that
Newton's Laws just say uh the the law of
friction says in in sort of Newton's law
terms it says there's a force the law of
friction says there's a force it's force
is equal to well mu * n the coefficient
of friction times the So-Cal normal
force which is how much you're pushing
down on the object how much you're
trying to push the object into the
surface that that you're sort of sliding
it relative to and so in when you put
that into
Newton's uh Laws of Motion what it's
going to say is well the friction force
is resisting motion so that means that
if force is equal to mass time
acceleration there's a force the
frictional force that is opposing the
direction of motion so the friction
force will always make the thing slow
down it will always make there be an
acceleration that's in the opposite
direction so the thing will slow down
and eventually it will come to rest and
that's that's so so in a sense as you as
you sub substitute in the formula for
frictional force into Newton's Second
Law you get this result that says the
effect of the frictional force will be
that the thing will eventually come to
rest now there are there are many pieces
to this complicated so for example uh
friction ordinary friction is a story
about Solid Surfaces sort of rubbing
against each other but there's also an
analog of friction in gases and liquids
so the analog of friction in a gas is
that there is a drag on an object moving
through the gas so if you throw a ball
the ball will not if if you throw a ball
in in in space or on the moon or
something like this where there's no no
atmosphere there's no air the ball will
will only have the only force acting on
it will be gravity if you throw a ball
on the on the earth not only will
gravity be acting on it but also there's
a drag Force that's essentially the
analog of friction in the air so what's
happening well you know the the ball has
to kind of slide through the air it has
to there are all these air molecules
that are bouncing around and they're
hitting the hitting the um the ball and
so on but what the ball has to do is to
push those air molecules out of the way
to make its way through the air and as
it pushes those air molecules out of the
way those air molecules change their
motion that's what it means for it to
push it out of the way the a molecule
hits the ball the ball is the molecule
is is bounced away so to speak by the
presence of the ball well it turns out
that you can work out that uh effect of
the the the sort of the the drag of um
on the on the ball by having to move the
air molecules same thing happens in
water with liquids for example the
liquid molecules out of the way the
molecules are always moving around so
there'll always be a path you know with
a solid the ball will just stop at the
solid surface you can't move those atoms
in the solid but with a gas or liquid
those atoms are always moving around so
you can always sort of find that with
the the ball can always push its way
through the liquid or the or the gas
but as it does so it has to rearrange
the molecules and what will happen when
it rearranges the molecules well it's
kind of like what happens in the
molecules in in um uh when you're
rubbing Solid Surfaces you'll produce
some some sort of extra Motion in those
microscopic molecules which will turn
into eventually heat random motion of
those molecules so you throw a ball
through the air it has a certain drag
and it's actually pretty complicated to
work out the the drag if the if the if
you're going through water for example
uh I should explain that um the amount
of
drag uh there there
are uh four parameters that affect the
actual force on an object going through
air or or water or a gas or or liquid
the four parameters are how big is the
object what is the density of the
material like air has very low density
water has a higher density means a
higher mass per unit volume um the so
the how big is the object what's the
density of the material how fast is the
object going and a fourth parameter
which is the so-call viscosity of the
material so what is viscosity viscosity
is the resistance it's a little bit like
a coefficient of friction but it isn't
defined the same way at all it's kind of
how much does does the material resist
being moved so a typical measure of
viscosity is you've got um uh let's see
you've got for example two plates and
they've got fluid between them and the
question is how much force does it take
to move one plate relative to the other
knowing that what you're really doing is
the plates aren't touching so there's no
friction but what's happening is there's
fluid in between them and you're trying
to slide you're trying to make it so
that the so that the uh uh let's say one
plate is moving at a certain speed the
other plate is is stationary how much
force is there um that is associated
with the the molecules so that the
molecules in the fluid they hit one
plate they just might say bounce
straight up they hit the other plate
they bounce in a different direction how
much does that bouncing in a different
direction thing have the effect of sort
of pulling you back as you slide these
plates
and that the quantity that determines
that is called viscosity it's measured
in units of usually called centio as the
a Poise is a unit of viscosity it's
actually very big unit so usually
centipoise is what's what's used to
determine viscosity so if you pour water
you can see sort of how it pours and and
how how it sort of uh how it starts
moving is determined by its viscosity if
you pour syrup treal in in British
English if you pour that it pours much
less easily and that's because it has
higher viscosity it has a higher
resistance to starting to move so when
you try and pour it and you've got that
jug or something and you're trying to
get the Liquid to not be in The Jug but
to be moving and and falling out of The
Jug um when you have higher viscosity
you have um uh it's more difficult for
it to do that it it flows less easily
what determines viscosity it's a
detailed that it's a matter of detailed
properties of the material uh in the
case of a gas there's a fairly simple
formula for the viscosity in the case of
a liquid it's been super difficult to
work out viscosities and pretty much
hasn't been done uh it's it's how you
know Computing the viscosity of water is
I think still undoable um from first
principles Computing viscosity of air is
pretty easy um there's there's simply I
could even probably explain how one does
it um it just has to do with when you're
looking at these these molecules they're
hitting one side they're they're going
to hit the other side they they they hit
other molecules a certain number of of
times um in in between and uh you're
sort of continually
transferring momentum from one one side
to the other and the rate at which that
happens is essentially determined by the
number of molecules that are there and
their average
speed so anyway
the um uh there there are these four
quantities the size of the object the
speed of the object the density of the
fluid it's going through and the
viscosity of the fluid it's going
through and it turns out those four
quantities are the only things that the
drag on an object or the the kind of the
form of you essentially the drag on an
object can depend on when you look at
the the sort of the the as as an object
moves through a FL fluid the fluid will
make all sorts of edies and all kinds of
other shapes and so on behind it um and
what determines that is just some
combination of those quantities so
there's this neat trick called
dimensional analysis which says okay
we've got these quantities and they each
have certain units there's length
there's a length unit there's a velocity
that's length per unit time there's a um
uh there's a a density that's Mass
divided by length cubed and then
viscosity I believe the units of that
are mass length mass over length over
time I think um anyway what what when
you have these three quantities and you
know that the properties that you get
out are just they don't depend on the
overall size of the object they only
depend on some combination of those
quantities and turns out there's just
one way of combining those quantities to
make something that doesn't have units
doesn't have dimensions of length or
something like this it's a thing called
the Reynolds number and it is uh let's
see what is it it's
some
uh it
is length times yeah it's it's size
times
velocity divided by uh viscosity over a
density if I remember correctly
um and uh so that means means what does
that mean that means if
you uh
decrease if if that that's telling you
that what mostly matters is the size of
an object multiplied by velocity it's
going and um the uh um uh the the so
okay what what effect does that have if
you look at the pattern of fluid flow uh
when you move your finger through some
water for example you'll see when you
move it fairly slowly you'll see these
couple of edies forming behind it and so
on if you were to look at uh and there's
a certain speed at which you'll see
different form of flow if you look at
something really big like a ship uh well
you could compare the flow behind a ship
the flow behind an airplane they're
going at very different speeds they're
going but they're going in materials
different materials um there will be a a
a speed for the ship size of ship a
speed for the airplane size for the
airplane at which the form of the flow
will be the same even though one is in
air one is in water they're different
they're going at different speeds and so
on the flow is determined only by the
Reynolds number so in a first
approximation the the Reynolds number is
what determines for example whether the
whether the flow is smooth or laminina
whether in a sense the fluid is just
sort of sliding past the object or
whether the fluid is kind of getting
caught on the object and making all this
sort of turbulent mess like you would
see in a waterfall or something like
this and for many things the the sort of
critical reals number is about 100 some
other ones is around a thousand it
depends a bit on the shape of the object
but um that determines if if you were to
have a a um a big thing going very
slowly or a smaller thing going very
fast all that matters in determining the
structure of the flow is the Reynolds
number okay so now now why am I telling
you all of this we talking about kind of
the frictional
effects of of fluids on things moving
through them so you throw a ball and the
ball has a certain drag force on it
that's associated with having to move
the air out of the way as the ball goes
through okay so that drag force is quite
hard to compute if the ball is moving
slowly enough if you drop a little
little sphere through some uh thick
mineral oil or something or or through
syrup or something like that in that
case there's a lovely formula it's
called stokes's law and it says that the
um see if I can get it right it's 6 Pi 8
AV I think is the the force is 6 pi
times the viscosity times the the radius
of the sphere times the velocity it's
very simple formula and that determines
the the essentially the the force that's
the drag Force that's pushing back
relative to the thing falling through
the material um or or being thrown
through the material so that's what
happens at very at very low Reynolds
numbers uh as soon as you get to the
Reynolds numbers that correspond to
throwing a ball through the air there
much higher Reynolds numbers there
turbulent flow behind the ball and the
roughly uh the Well in that stokes's law
thing the the the force the the drag
force is proportional to the speed at
which the thing is going through the
through the through the fluid as you get
to larger speeds larger Reynolds numbers
or larger objects um the drag Force
becomes proportional to the square of
the speed and so that that means things
slow down more quickly so to speak okay
what consequence does that have well one
consequence it has is if you have an
object and you like drop something out
of an airplane it'll fall through the
air if you're crazy enough to go and uh
do um skydiving or something then you
know you fall through the air at a
certain speed and what happens is
there's a a drag Force that's that's the
air pushing back on you the force of
gravity is making you fall the drag
force is causing you to is trying to
prevent you from falling and that drag
Force if you work out the equations the
the the thing that's making you go
faster if if it wasn't for the air you
would just the force of gravity is
constant so the force is constant the
that means that you have a according to
Newton's Second Law you have a constant
acceleration so your speed which started
off at zero when you were on you know at
least the vertical speed started off at
zero when you're on the plane and you
jump out of the plane and you start
falling and you start falling and as the
the the longer you go the faster you're
falling if there wasn't any air there in
fact you would go the speed you would go
at would increase with time just
linearly with time so after 1 second I
happen to know because I know the
formulas that you'd be going at 9.8
meters per second and after two seconds
you'd be going at twice that speed after
3 seconds three times that speed and so
on you just keep going faster but that
doesn't it really works because there's
this drag Force associated with you
falling through the air and eventually
the drag Force balances the force of
gravity and so you get to What's called
the terminal velocity you end up getting
to a speed at which the force of gravity
pulling you down is equal to the drag
Force pushing you up and I think it's
like 100 miles an hour or something for
a typical you know person it it depends
on whether you're you know you can go
faster if you if you make your area your
cross-sectional area smaller by kind of
you know diving through the air so to
speak as opposed to sort of making
yourself as big as possible and the the
limiting case of that is a parachute
where the the idea in a parachute is to
make your area as big as possible so
that the the the drag Force increases
with the area and so when you have a big
parachute the drag force is very big and
so the the terminal velocity is very
small small enough that well it's I
don't think it's trivial even to land
when you're using a parachute you have
to kind of be careful to not break your
leg when you land and such like but but
it is a a a a reasonable speed rather
than 100 miles an hour um and so that is
determined by the terminal velocity
associated with this great big parachute
as compared to the terminal velocity
associated with the smaller object and
and that's so that's that's kind of the
the interpretation of of uh uh sort of
the analog of friction the effect of
friction
but not friction in solid objects
grinding against each other but this
other friction like effect that is drag
forces or viscosity um in the air but by
the way I should say that
um the uh
what drag is not only associated with
viscosity viscosity is a microscopic
phenomenon like friction of sort of
individual molecules doing their thing
drag is also sort of just the the large
scale pushing of the air out to the side
and that that large scale effect that's
kind of a a more inertial kind of effect
and that's a different effect from the
viscosity effect and uh sort of in the
the um particularly when you're going
fast the that's the major effect is just
you got to push the air molecules out of
the
way there are there are other effects
and this is a complicated area I mean
there are other places where you can ask
about sort of Newton's Law meets the
real world another one another
complicated messy area is this thing
called the coefficient of
restitution uh so coefficient of
friction is about sliding we've got drag
which is associated with pushing through
through something like the air another
thing is you take a rubber ball you drop
it on the ground it bounces up again
okay so what's happening there is the
the the coefficient of restitution is
kind of if if the thing falls down and
hits the ground with a certain speed the
it will then bounce back with it will
bounce up again so we revers the
velocity you you've made it go instead
of going down it goes up but how fast
does it go up relative to the amount it
went down so the coefficient of
restitution is the ratio of those things
so for example a typical might be three
or something if you have a a pretty good
you know if you have a Super Bowl or
whatever they're called um they'll
they'll bounce up almost as high as as
you drop them and that means that they
coefficient of restitution is close to
one which means when you when they hit
the ground at a certain speed they'll
bounce back at about the same speed
which means they'll they'll go up to the
same height and so on um and uh what
determines that coefficient of
restitution oh boy that's a mess um I
mean it is determined by kind of the
solid object analog of uh of
viscosity and um yeah it's it's just
really complicated actually uh and it's
it's sort of an advanced end of solid
mechanics that is mostly just you just
measure it and see what comes out um
it's you know it's it's hard to work out
but that's another piece when you're
solving Newton's equations and you're
solving it for a bouncing ball one of
the things you have to do is figure out
when it bounces uh when you know when it
bounces back how much does it bounce
when it bounces and that's that's not
something you can deduce from Newton's
Laws alone that's something where you
have have to know lots of detailed
properties and materials and even then
you can't compute it you pretty much
just have to measure it
nowadays let's
see
uh
[Music]
um well there's another question here
you guys are really EXC izing my uh kind
of can I actually
explain uh well physics but you know the
problem with explaining physics is that
there are things that are very clear-cut
and well understood and you know you'll
find in textbooks of high school
physics then there are things that are
often assumptions that are made there
that are extremely not well understood
and you know when you ask questions
about I don't know a bouncing ball for
example example uh you might find well
yes you can apply Newton's laws and it's
all great except well you got this
scishion into restitution what the heck
is that well that's really hard to
compute and that's a whole different
story of physics it's physics as well
but it's not it's not sort of clear-cut
high school level
physics so Paula asks here how do
Newton's Laws of Motion apply to objects
moving in in circular
motion that's sort of high school level
physics and sort of more complicated so
the people you take you have a string
you have something tied at the end of
the string and you whirl it around
everybody knows that the string will try
and it'll try and pull itself away from
you um and that is often referred to as
centrifugal force that the thing will
will Centra Fugal Fugal comes from the
Latin fio I guess to run away from um
and uh you know that's running away from
the center Force so the it's it's the
thing is effectively pulling away from
you and and then people will say in
physics textbooks no no no you shouldn't
talk about centrifugal force you should
only talk about centripetal force um and
uh this is all gets very confusing first
point okay you Newton's first law says
if you don't act on something with a
force it'll just keep going in a
straight line it'll just keep going in
the same direction Forever at the same
velocity that is the same speed in the
same direction okay so that means if you
want to keep something going in a circle
you got to put some you got to you've
got to exert a force on it other words
just can keep going in a straight line
so for example so that's why you know
when your string you you have got to be
pulling on that string to get the object
not to just fly off in some
Direction so that centripetal force is
the force on the object that's pulling
it in to keep it uh to keep it a fixed
distance you know that the the to to
keep it just the distance that this that
the Tor string is rather than sort of
whizzing off to infinity and so that and
in order to keep it at that distance you
have to exert a certain force and
depending on how fast the thing is going
around that force will be higher the
faster it's going around and the um the
basic point is what you've got to do is
okay so here's here's the thing left to
its own devices the object will just
keep going in a straight line it would
take its velocity velocity is speed in a
certain direction would keep it constant
but what you've got to do is to change
the velocity you're not changing its
overall speed but you're changing the
direction of the speed and so that
change of the direction of the speed is
like uh is is again a form of
acceleration one form of acceleration is
just you're going in a certain direction
you change the speed at which you're
going in that direction but you you
could also be changing the direction of
the speed and in order to do that you
have to say well I was going at this
speed in this direction but now I want
to reduce the amount that I'm going in
that direction and instead going this
other direction and that corresponds to
changing the speed that corresponds to
an acceleration so that's why it's the
the necessity if you want to keep the
thing going in a circle the necessity of
changing its velocity is means that you
it has to be accelerating in order for
it to accelerate you have to exert a
force on it that's the force that you're
pulling on it with with a string with
and so you know what's an application of
that well if you have something being
pulled towards the center of the Earth
by gravity and yet uh and and you want
it okay so a a spacecraft that was just
tooling along in interplanetary
interstellar space nowhere near any
planets or stars or anything like that
it's just going to keep going in a
straight line in a first approximation
that's Newton's first law if it gets
near the earth the earth will make it
will exert a force of gravity on it and
so it will pull it towards the Earth but
the whole point is that you can get a
situation where you have an orbit where
the thing has has to be pulled by a
certain Force it's being pulled by a
certain force of gravity it is that
force is causing the thing to change its
acceleration I'm sorry to change its
velocity and you can arrange things so
that you've you've got the the um at the
right speed the there'll be a match
between the acceleration that's comes
from the force being exerted by by
gravity and the acceleration needed to
just sort of uh slip around the Earth in
an orbit and so for low earth orbit that
speed is about 17,000 mil an hour if
you're going at that speed you will be
the the kind of the the the the force of
gravity just matches what you need to
change your velocity so that you just
keep going around the earth and for
different planets that speed is
different um and uh uh that that's the
um uh so that that that's kind of an
application of kind of circular motion
and forces in circular motion um the
uh uh yeah let's now when when it comes
to if you really want to get complicated
okay we we'll skip to something a much
more complicated version of circular
motion um a very confusing thing about
the universe is how rotation works in
the whole
universe maybe we won't get maybe we
won't talk about that we can talk about
um
uh well there's a there's a a kind of a
circular motion phenomenon in black
holes that's pretty funky um
when if usually the force of gravity
just pulls things right into the center
of like on the earth in a first
approximation the force of gravity just
pulls everything towards the center of
the earth it's not precisely the center
of the earth there's usually you know
one and a thousand deviation from it
just going towards the center because
the density of rock in different places
is different and so on but in first
approximation just pulls it in towards
the center okay there is an exception to
this there are uh black holes that were
formed from the collapse of a star that
was spinning around
rapidly probably the details of exactly
how that formation process works are not
well understood but probably that leads
to black holes that are effectively
spinning I say effectively spinning
because there's really nothing about the
black hole that allows you to tell that
it's spinning because a black hole it's
like having a perfect sphere you you
can't if if you're just looking at the
perfect sphere from the outside and it's
a perfect perfect sphere it's just you
know the fact that it might be turning
around you can't tell it's just there's
a sphere there um you'd have to have
some little bit on the surface that you
can see oh yeah that got moved around
but if the sphere is really perfect you
can't tell that it's moving that it's
spinning from a distance okay so so it
is with black holes they're very perfect
and they're the sort of perfect spheres
but there are a type of black holes
called Curve black holes that have the
property that the the um the so in black
holes you there's sort of a a black
holes more or less
um most of what you talk about in black
holes is the gravitational field in a
black hole what's inside it and whether
there's a crushed star inside it or
whether there's something different
inside it you can't tell from the
outside all you can tell from the
outside is what the gravitational field
looks like what the what the force due
to gravity looks like okay so in these
black holes that have this the spin
parameter there's this weird thing that
happens called frame dragging and what
happens is that everything that the
force of gravity is not just going
towards the center the force of gravity
is something that causes object to get
sort of dragged in a circular motion
around this black hole so that's a funky
effect and uh you can um uh you can get
well all kinds of all kinds of
interesting things happening there uh an
example of another weird effect in
circular motion is a photon so photons
of particles of light uh they have well
they have zero Mass but they can have a
certain energy one of the really funky
things that can happen with black holes
is that photons can orbit black holes so
normally you know you have a satellite
orbiting the Earth it's a massive object
or orbiting this massive Planet but in
in that one of the weirder things that
can happen with with particularly with
these spinning black holes is that you
can have a a photon that has an does it
happen with non-spinning ones I'm not
sure I think not for some reason you can
have photons that orbit the black hole
so you can have essentially light
continually circulating around this
black hole it never gets it never
escapes it never goes off to Infinity
it's just hanging out there circulating
around the black hole just another weird
thing to to a weird effect all right
maybe one more question we seem to be on
a a um uh uh quotes Elementary
physics
uh story here
um well there was a meta question here
how would you structure a discussion on
introduction physics so if you mean if
you were going to explain
physics uh
without kind of from scratch what would
you talk
about you
know I
think the thing is
physics gives you kind of simple explan
Elementary physics is about giving you
simple explanations for certain kinds of
things that happen in the world and
there are lots of things that happen in
the world where there isn't a simple
explanation that can be given there are
lots of things in the world where maybe
the microscopic rules that determine it
are simple but the actual phenomenon is
quite complicated and you can't
necessarily work out how it will work
without just sort of following all those
microscopic rules so if you ask what is
is what can you say that's easy to talk
about in physics there are different
areas there's mechanics the story of
motion the story of forces things like
this we we just talked about a bunch of
those kinds of effects there's a certain
distance you can go where you are able
to sort of talk about things in simple
ways when you have things like friction
or coefficient of restitution or
viscosity something like that the
microscopic details of what produces
those things is often very hard to
explain but if you just say and let's
assume the coefficient of friction is.3
then you can work out the mechanics uh
around that that's one area another area
is Optics properties of light there's a
a bunch that you can see fairly easily
with um uh with kind of the um with
things like lenses and so on again in a
lens light is bent due to the so-call
refractive index the speed of light is
different inside the glass than it is in
in the vacuum if you say why is it
different that can actually be worked
out the the refractive index is not so
hard to work out in in at least certain
simple cases um the uh but again it's
much more complicated than sort of
Elementary physics to work out the
refractive index you just say okay the
refractive index of water is 1.33 we
don't really know why but if we assume
that we know light goes 1.33 times
slower and water than does in air and we
can make certain conclusions about
refraction and so on from it so there's
a little slice of Optics that you can
work out Optics is actually pretty good
in this respect there's a lot you can
work out in Optics um where you're just
following fairly simple formulas and so
on electricity and
magnetism there are again certain things
you can work out fairly easily mostly
having to do with what electromagnetic
fields do when they're not inside
materials and so on uh what happens when
you have sort of working out when is
there magnetism in a material when is a
material or superconductor or something
these are very hard to work out but if
you say well the material just has such
and such a property what consequences
does it have for the electric field the
magnetic field that's fairly easy to
work out the um uh people long ago used
to teach fluid mechanics a lot in in in
physics they don't teach it very much
anymore mostly because there's rather
little that can be said simply about it
there are rather few formulas that work
there mostly it's pretty hard to compute
what happens the flow of fluids around
you know an airplane or something very
hard to work out you know the the uh
working out things like this drag
coefficient I think I told you the one
formula that's uh that's a um sort of an
easy to work out well it's not so easy
to work the formula out although it's
not undoable um but uh once simple
formula there but fluid mechanics tends
not to be taught so much in elementary
physics um the
uh let's see the other another big area
is thermodynamics the story of heat and
temperature and so on and again if you
assume certain properties of materials
you just say the specific heat of this
is blah then you can uh do calculations
there's a sort of domain of calculations
that are fairly easy to do like if you
put certain certain amount of heat into
a substance then the temperature will
increase by something that's
proportional to the so-called specific
heat well the the the specific heat
times the temperature gives you the the
heat that you have to put in to raise
the thing by that temperature and so on
then of course things complicated things
happen like you know uh water can boil
into steam the process by which that
boiling happens is very hard to work out
still not completely understood but you
can just say and by the way at 100
degrees Centigrade at normal pressure
water will turn into steam and you can
work out things assuming that fact but
to work out that fact is hard and
actually as yet
undoable uh so you know the the the
story of Elementary physics is a story
of of kind of navigating between these
different things that are hard and and
the fact that there is a path between
the hard things is is is actually kind
of interesting it's it's same thing
happens in mathematics there are
question you can ask in mathematics that
you study in elementary mathematics that
are that are askable and then there are
other questions where it's like no
nobody knows the answer to that uh
things like you know if you look at
prime numbers and you look at um uh at
twin primes like like um 11 and 13
primes that are two apart nobody knows
whether there are an infinite number of
twin primes that's an elementary thing
to ask but it's very hard to answer but
there are questions in mathematics you
can say for example every number has a
unique decomposition as a product of
primes that's something which for 2,000
years people have kind of actually when
was that proved that was proved not sure
that was proved um uh that was probably
more recent than that I don't think that
was known to uid and people like that
but in any case it's something you can
work out but so in mathematics like in
physics there are things that are sort
of elementarily workable out there are
things where we humans can readily see
what's going on and there are things
kind of if we step off the the path we
quickly go into the jungle and we
quickly go into things where it's very
hard to answer and same happens in
physics so there are these particular
areas of physics where it's been
possible to kind of navigate through and
and get to easy answers and there are
general principles about how physics
Works where it isn't as easy to sort of
do the exercise work out the numbers and
so on and those are quite robust and
those are those are interesting areas to
explain if you're explaining sort of
phys physics now you know the other
thing that the things I've just
mentioned are kind of the main areas of
Elementary physics kind of the next big
story is the story of how atoms work and
how quantum mechanics works and so on
that tends to be sort of a more advanced
discussion in physics um I'm hoping that
it won't need to be more advanced I'm
hoping that as we understand more from
our physics project about how quantum
mechanics really works that it will be
possible to discuss that in almost as
Elementary a way as all these other
things
but um and then we have uh there are
aspects of physics which are actually
pretty easy to explain but which tend
not to get explained in elementary
physics probably the most notable of
those is particle physics where the the
Dynamics of how particles interact when
they Collide and all that kind of thing
very complicated but the basic statement
that you know a proton has three quarks
roughly in it two up quarks and a down
Quark that's pretty easy to understand
understand a neutron has an up quark and
two down quarks and so on and it's
pretty easy it's a matter of just simple
arithmetic to say okay you know these
quarks have these properties these
electric charges etc etc etc what
consequence does that have for these
particles and there's a sort of zoo of
particles and it's pretty easy to work
out what particles can exist on the
basis of these different combinations of
quarks and so on it's always been
surprising to me that because in the
history of physics all the stuff about
particle physics got worked out through
very sophisticated mathematics and so on
but the results do not require that the
results are pretty easy to explain but
yet at least in the US it tends to be
the case that there isn't really a
discussion of those things in quotes
Elementary physics even though there
certainly could be um because it
actually isn't it isn't complicated
there's nothing you don't need to know
fancy math even though that was how
people historically got there in the
1950s 1960s and so on you don't need to
know that to understand it
uh similarly when it comes to things to
do with gravity and black holes and so
on there's a fair distance you can get
without fancy math um and I think
actually our physics project gives you
even further that you can get without
fancy math but it also shows you if you
step far off the path it's it's really a
a very dense jungle out there um and
that dense jungle is has a lot of things
to say about what is predictable in the
world and what's not but actually one of
the things it does tend to say is that
by very by the very fact that you know
the jungle is dense you know there's
lots of sort of Randomness and
complexity going on even that fact alone
gives you certain simplifying
consequences that allow you to make
statements all right well we should
probably wrap up there and uh so thanks
for
um joining me and
um uh bye for
now